this is super impressive honestly these
are just still cars they're pushing off
of still cars
good makes it practical in cg also
practical cg yeah this is all old
classic epic meal time dude look at that
jank motion player this is what like got
me going into my next phase of action
visual effects real quick guest react
real quick
what's up guys welcome back to vfx
artists reacting today we have a very
special guest that's right it's freddy
hey everybody best bud freddy so
arguably both us and yourself freddie
kind of got our start in youtube doing
visual effects videos yeah kind of where
it all started was
computers and making stuff that people
weren't doing at that time
maybe in close
so the reason i picked this one is
because the effects on it are really
damn good for what you guys were doing
back in the day this is clint back on
his old beater right yep yeah throw this
through fell apart
all right so pause it right there this
is a full comp
what is it it's a full cop so that's
clint just like sitting there the thing
that sells this one i remember sitting
there on this one little speedometer
moves oh yeah a little lamborghini
speedometer moving
that's just driving along that street
not fast
but that's real
working that green screen green screen
in front and this is positive per second
this is uh in the car
with a leaf blower being blown up my
hair in order to sell that
this is super impressive honestly these
are just still cars you're pushing off
of steel cars and the wheel
is fake and those cars are being comped
onto this background and the wheels are
being made to spin after the fact
that's great that charger is great this
is alessandra just rolling on re-screen
on the ground steady and then really the
impact on this gets sold 100 just like
just going like this
you guys turned this around in a week
right this is a week yeah man i think
this is a testament to just like if you
film the elements for real even if
they're comp together it goes so much
farther to making things look real
do you think if you made that video
these days you think it'd still get
attention and views you know i think i
think one of the hard things about being
able to do a one-to-one on this is that
you know this was like during this
height of momentum of youtube stuff the
problem with these videos was like when
we were doing one a week the whole point
was like there were like three panel
comics right this is just like a little
very short stories you know i think that
the way people are using youtube is
different right like this as a
tick tock probably could play as we as
weird as it is right because that i
think is where the format of this sort
of thing is
epic meal time and freddy wong what you
know about video editing software
dude this gets this video gets quoted to
me all the time really yeah more camera
shake too much camera shake this isn't
born identity yeah this was all old
classic epic meal time and this was just
us kind of taking the piss out of what
you expect from visual effects also that
jank motion blur oh dude look at that
jang motion blur it's like the image
based like smearing motion blur
yeah it's the hard smear physics you can
drop a couple objects and have them
bounce and they bounce a little janky
these days you got chunks in your video
games flying all over the place take it
for granted it was barely something you
could do back then like this had to be
calculated in our cpu and you could do
this in real time now on a gpu easily
yeah
cars
this was a mostly branded um effects
stuff he did a lot he was he was of the
duo he was the one doing all the 3d
elements and then i'm sitting there
being like i can animate the planet
this video
made everybody think that i'm a really
short guy
but no i'm average height harley is a
really tall guy yeah i play the vr game
with harley and it's like literally
the model didn't even know what to do
let me tell you guys to leave a comment
with some awesome clips that we should
check out maybe it's something we've
made and you love maybe it's something
you've seen in a movie theater or maybe
it's something you've seen on netflix or
another fun streaming service let us
know this was underrated in my opinion
because i think the movie also knows
what it's doing it knows that it's kind
of a joke
there's a big magnet by the way sam he's
pulling everybody around gotcha it's a
really nice looking movie i mean all of
michael bay stuff looks this is a
microwave movie yeah what and by the way
you can always tell when someone tries
to fake the michael bay funk it's never
as good the michael bay like long you
know super long zoom shot right like the
spin around look at that in bad boy
three look at that in bad boys too it
feels different it's better in bad boys
too
good mix of practical and cg also
practical cg like there's a bunch of
digital doubles but you don't
immediately register them because
there's a lot of there's a lot of real
people in this yeah exactly and you cut
right into a real person to sell the hit
when you use the digital double defense
and also a lot of good like fast fast
fast slow fast fast right like the mix
of of slow motion and quit and regular
speed michael bay feels like a kid that
was okay with like playing in mud when
he was a kid right like when you look at
this shot you got smoke you have debris
loose debris that stuff sells the invite
that stuff sells the chaos of it by the
way john woo does that really well too
right like all the drunk gunfight stuff
it's like the amount of just stuff
getting thrown in the air
most movies when you do action
especially chaos action it's just chaos
right it's chaos chaos chaos and maybe
you have some good rhythm videos look at
camera work but this there's a story in
every single shot like dude's getting
his vest pulled off causing me get
thrown differently guy hits the rail
then a bull smacks him in the face
that's sort of constant checking in is
like that's a commercial thing 30
seconds you only have so much to tell
you guys seen the michael bay got milk
commercial right no and now let's make
that random call with today's ten
thousand dollar question this dude went
so hard on a got milk commercial who
shot alexander hamilton every shot here
is like so yeah beautifully composed
right like the wide angles the camera's
pushing in
excuse me
the dueling pistol that flashes the gun
shooting it's a totally information
dense
uh
thing and i think that when you look at
action scenes and we look at visual
effects too you can get dents you want
to tell that story both in the frame and
then also in your cuts
do you stand in the line at the prison
cafeteria where the chef google takes
its serving spoon and reaches into a pot
of slurry and slaps it on your bowl and
you look down its vfx artist react or do
you go to a supper club and look at a
menu
order this video upon request yeah click
subscribe
this sequence has some of the most
intense action visuals oh my god all the
time the funny thing is like most of the
movie kind of is whatever until the end
no it is a boring movie and then the
hardest five minutes you've ever seen on
camera
oh my god oh my god it's amazing there's
nothing else like this man this is what
like got me going into my next phase of
action visual effects real quick guest
react real quick the show in the
beginning so he takes the gun
and then he turns uh i know right like
oh my god look at the quality of that
blood bonk i am blown away so was he
it's the chunky there's this chunkiness
that's going on here it's a chunky
gloopiness obviously it defies physics
with how much blood is coming out of
these people the amount of blood that's
coming out of people would like change
the relative humidity of this area
oh there's more there's more meat more
meat coming in
oh here we go here it comes the vfx shot
this is why we watched the whole scene
man
dude chopped his fingers off too i never
noticed that
double roll
so after he mutilates the dudes in the
truck here frame by frame on this just
[Laughter]
i know it's a yeah that's a dummy right
that's just because that's what well
that's a dude that's been painted for
one frame yeah yeah and then they just
blew up and there's like so much it's
the string it's the viscosity of it this
little hat flies up see that right here
we go right right here he goes
there's the hat straight up straight up
hats off to rambo i think he's shooting
actual blanks there too like that's just
part of what's causing the chaos is he
just letting rip these giant blanks that
are basically explosions in and of
themselves so there's another shot after
this that is vfx related
so check out what's happening to the
people in that shot
so we're painting out ahead so all this
blood i'm pretty sure is cg yes yeah the
guy uh second from the right
so we have a blood hit here but what
sells that effect is the paint outs they
do look at that a little separation at
the waist that those are full 3d legs
you're right those are full 3d lights
and they're basically him out after this
they're doing a wire pull on him but
painting out his legs it's happening in
the chaos of the shot and there's so
much happening that's the one thing you
see in that shot right you don't you may
not necessarily notice the guy's head is
gone but you remember that one guy that
first pit here's the thing i've been
i've been wanting to see us on hollywood
movies forever and they never do it and
that is bullet penetration with squibs
they always do like a hip but you'll
never see like a hit and then another
squib lined up with that to imply the
path of a bullet penetrating something
and you get it here
their arms are up to avoid getting hit
by the scopes i bet you they're stacked
up yeah so that they don't actually hurt
each other yeah actually huge those are
huge explosives on them those are real
squibs too those aren't cg at all but
notice they have a squib on the front of
the first guy and then the front and the
back the second guy and they're slightly
offset so you get to travel through them
by the way even though they have padding
on those squares that's still like
getting punched
really hard on both sides of your body
imagine having two explosions go off on
your abdomen
so this is i think this is like almost
like an afterthought in terms of visual
effects but it worked really well
[Music]
all right so go back first that first
slice
his hand goes across the knife cuts his
fingers off it's not a full blade they
cg the blade
the end of it yeah yeah yeah and it's
also it's also getting obscured by i
think they're probably adding blood to
it so yeah basically that blood coming
off the side yeah almost could even be a
thing where you have like a tiny like
blunt hook on a blood bag and it's like
a half prop blade and so he is kind of
like legit tearing it and they're also
painting out uh what's what's probably a
seam in his shirt there's definitely a
seam there that's already been cut oh
yeah that's true yeah yeah it's been
painted out as well so then the final
right here as it gets
[Music]
the kicked goes up
that's off the rambo hats off to rambo
this top half moves separately from the
bottom half and it's a relatively simple
effect because you just roto out your
top half and you roll your bottom half
and just have them play at different
speeds and then also you can see all the
painted on like blood stains like on his
back and on the side there that's all
added after the fact i'm noticing
they're also adding little splits and
splurts onto the ground there yep
that was a lot of really great clips and
also freddie thank you for joining us
thank you guys
it's great to hear your insights on this
stuff and also kind of like talk about
these clips that we have these shared
experiences with and i don't know it's
really exciting freddy i hear you have a
really great d and d podcast dungeons
and dragons podcast it's called dungeons
and daddies it's on spotify it's on
podcast apps you can also listen in your
browser if you're a psychopath
dungeons.com or search for it on uh
podcast apps and spotify